hello everybody welcome to this lecture
grandmaster choice
my name is pepe wenka it's a great
pleasure to be here with all of you guys
and what did i choose
for today's lecture well i'm going to
show you the best
me high tal's sacrifices mihail
tao the eighth world champion one of the
best chess players in history
and as you guys know he was born in
latvia and
he's known to be a fantastic uh
attacking player right and uh he has uh
created like extremely great
uh games right and uh we all miss him
right
and uh today i'm going to show you two
games
the first one uh corresponds to a game
that he played against
mikhail bodbinic in their world
championship match
and the second game is a game that he
played against
bent larsen so i see already some people
in the chat what's up mr democracy how
are you doing
so uh i hope you guys interact with me
during the lecture i'll be asking you
some questions and please give me your
suggestions and this way will be
more fun right so yes mikhail versus
mihail
and this is one of my favorite chess
games so
i hope you guys enjoy this game as much
as as i did analyzing
okay so mikhail bienick went for c4
and uh mikhail tal replies with knight
f6
knight f3 g6 and now mikhail tal is
showing his intentions to go for the
king's indian
and as you guys know he's he was a very
uh
[Music]
great player uh using this kind of uh
openings right aggressive openings okay
so
g3 going for the fiance set up bishop g7
bishop g2
sure castles shortcut sorry d4 and
d6 of course black can try to go for the
groomful setup with c6 and d5
which is more solid but mikhail tal
wants some action and he goes for d6
knight c3 and here there are different
uh
setups for white you guys know how this
line is called after knight c6 maybe you
know this
it's called the pano variation pano er
pano is a fantastic player from
argentina he's still alive
but he was one of the best chess players
in in his time yeah
so knight c6 black's idea has to go with
a6 and then maybe
rook b8 and b5 but okay
there are also other possibilities in
the game tal went for knight b to d7
which is
maybe the most natural move intend to go
e5 right trying to occupy the center
with some puns
but also you can employ this move c6
and then queen b6 or queen a5
are all possible right so for example
you are an attacking player as well you
can try this queen a5
and then whenever white goes for sure
castle you can transfer the queen
to the king side with queen h5 and
then bishop a3 and then knight g4 i call
this formation the
triangle right so let's say shark castle
and queen a5 let's say some stupid move
like i don't know a3
then queen h5 and then you can try to
attack
white's king with bishop a3 and knight
g4
this is a very dangerous formation
what's up blue
hope everything's fine in amsterdam such
a nice city yeah but
so chaotic with all the bicycles you
know i was getting lost
over there with so many bicycles like uh
and the trams and
it's just a fantastic place and uh okay
so knight b to d7 from mikhail tal
and now sure castle from mikhail would
pinik yeah let's call it the
bermuda triangle that's fine sure castle
are now
e5 finally black strikes in the center
and so me hell would be nick replies
with e4 occupying the center yeah
so here there are different alternatives
you can take on d4
in these positions and then uh black's
idea is just to put a knight on c5 then
a rook on e8
pawn on c6 pawn on a5 and then meanwhile
while white tries to go for h3 rookie 1
b3 bishop b2 or even bishop e3 followed
by
queen c2 and these positions are
actually very very rich
so that there are many different
alternatives here so e4 c6
mihaeltal starts with this move
controlling the d5 square
and white goes a3
a prophylactic move in many occasions
white wants to develop this bishop by
e3 and then uh there could be a knight
coming to g
for just putting pressure on this bishop
on e3 so that's why h3
is normally played in these positions
and now queen b6 from mihail tal just
putting pressure on d4 that could be
some tricks
on d4 so that's why white decides
to close the center can you give me any
other interesting moves here in this
position
uh besides d5
whenever there is a queen on b6 and then
two pawns on d4 and on c4
then that should draw your attention
so let's see what you guys play or what
are your candidate moves in this
position
come on blue give me some ops
bishop e6 bishop e6 i i guess you mean b
should be e3 the problem with bishop e3
is that the pawn on b2 is just hanging
you will love to play bishop e3 actually
then just to look with x-rays to this
screen but
b2 is just hanging so yeah not possible
to play bishop e3
c5 that's right my mem on car
that's right c5 is always a typical move
in this position because after d takes
e5 you want to take on e5 and then you
send this knight
to the cave on e8
and yeah this is playable i mean there
are also
some sacrifices with pawn e6 and then
knight g5
but okay the move that mikhail what mini
played
it's probably the most natural somebody
there in the chat is
suggesting rook b1 and then pawn takes b
pawn takes d4 is an option also queen b4
is an idea
in this kind of positions because you
can't protect the spawn
uh by playing b3 but okay white decide
to go
d5 now black takes c takes e5
c takes d5 and now knight c5 attacking
this pawn
on e4 so basically white has to protect
this pawn right
so what's the best way to do it just
removing this knight from f3
so in the game mihai bobby nick went for
91 which is pretty natural and then at
some point he's
aiming to go to d3 with this knight
removing this strong
knight on c5 so now how do do we develop
the pcc here for black well there are
different uh
available options for example you can
try to push
with f5 which is maybe the most natural
break
in this kind of positions right but also
you can try to develop the queen side
and this is what mikhail tal did with
the move bishop g7
in many occasions you want to play a5
because you want to guarantee this spot
for the knight on c5
right so in many occasions like what is
gonna try to
play some b4 and then therefore send it
this knight back
to some passive position so we don't
want to allow this so that's why
a5 is strong move in these positions
let's say
in the game bot minik went for knight d3
so how about if white plays rook b1 a5
on a3
what do we play here with the with the
black pieces
my friends this is a well-known theme
yeah
so whenever white tries a3
in these positions yeah exactly victor
a4 that's right so white is never going
to be able
to strike with b4 this is an alternative
you can also try to do something like
i don't know even rook c8 i mean it's
not the end of the wall if
white plays b4 right because we can take
and then knight a first
basically everything's fine here in this
position for black
but mikhail would be well for knight d3
knight takes d3
queen takes c3 and now rook f to c8
this is uh well this is uh one plan the
other plan
is just to go rook a to c8 but okay rook
f2 c8
and now white goes rook b1 in this
position
and mikhail tal goes for
knight h5 well what's his idea he wants
to
strike with f5 at some point rook b1 why
do we play rook b1 well because
white wants to develop the bishop to e3
and then he doesn't want to have
troubles on b2
so that's why rook b1 is more than
natural move in this position right
by the way guys after this lecture we'll
have another one
games of the week and then we'll check
one of the best games from norway chess
duda versus magnus carlsen he actually
finishes uh
the unbeaten straight from the world
champion 125 games
we'll check that later but now it's time
to focus on mikhail tao
so bishop e3 and now mihi
miki mikhail he goes for queen b4
okay and yeah whenever
white goes a3 black's idea is just to
put the queen on b3 which is
very well placed on that's out spot
right
so here white goes queen
e2 the idea you know
is to play prophylactically against the
move f5 because
usually i'm going to ask you one
question after white takes
on f5 how do we want to recapture an f5
with a pawn or the bishop
usually with the pawn right because we
want to gain control in the center
so that's why queen e2 is prophylactic
move in the sense that now after f5
if y takes then we can't take with the
pawn on g5
right on f5 sorry because the knight on
h5 is just uh
it's just hanging every russian
schoolboy knows omkar is saying
okay so now uh after queen e2 mikhail
plays
rook c4 you know very aggressive trying
to double rooks on the c file putting
pressure on e4 as well
uh mikhail bodbinic replies with rook
f2c1
trying to fight for the c file
rook ac8 from mikhail tal
and now king h2 from mikhail
but many kind of a waiting move right
finally
mikhail tal decides to strike in the
center
with f5 okay so what do you think
white's supposed to do in this position
you think white should take this pawn
or maybe play something else i don't
know
nico is smelling what happened in the
game actually he's saying
knight f4 is going to happen it's going
to happen somehow you are more than
right nico
this is actually what happened in this
fantastic game between mikhail chan and
mikhail budvinic
but we'll check that later so what do
you think
why should take on f5 or not
i guess at some point uh white should
take otherwise
maybe some f4 are even common for
example let's say you play something
stupid i don't know like rook c2 well
rook c2 actually branders right because
i can take on c3
so actually there are not so many moves
in this position right
so by but i mean i mean if white does
something like windy to f4 it's actually
very very very scary in this position so
that's why
black chicken f5 and now we are first to
take back with the bishop
and then only move rook a1
and now white is actually threatening to
uh
to play g4 so in this moment it's where
actually mihail tau starts playing
extremely creative
with a sacrifice and
the move is that that move that nico
suggested in the chat
exactly knight f4 sacrificing
a whole piece you know as you can see
the engine says he doesn't trust
this move but of course it's gonna be
extremely hard to play for for white in
this position
well white has to accept the challenge
otherwise
black can play knight d3 whenever you
move the queen or even knight takes e2
and now
white has lost this important bishop on
g2 and then
you know this position is just um you
know our dream when
we are playing with the kings india we
got the bishop pair the kings this week
we got
counter play on the c files basically
this is just very good for us right so
that's why
white is first to take on f4 and
he takes it for from mikhail bienick and
now i want to ask you what do you want
to play now there are so many subtleties
in this position and the engines
now they find good mods for white but i
can understand that
human being is not able to find this
little subtleties so what do you play
here with the white pieces
you don't have so many options right in
this position you can actually move the
bishop to two squares bishop d2
you can take on a7 and maybe you can
play some intermediate move a3
there are no more moves in this position
so bishop d2 somebody suggesting this is
actually what but being
played so what else
there is somebody who wants to take on
a7 why
is not good to take on a7
okay this is a blunder but let's try to
find out why
it's just a very simple move from black
here simple chess
just attack things and then sometimes
you'll manage to
grab those those things yeah take on a7
it would have to suffer
let's be more material up b6 well b6
b6 actually i'm not so sure about this
move because now
for example i don't know how you're
going to trap this bishop for example
let's say a4
queen a5 and then yeah you can actually
try to
well but then actually you can never
take on a7 because there's some knight
b5 so i'm not that sure
but the thing is queen a5 straight away
is actually stronger because
now you play a4 then
i think you can just play bishop e5
right now
and then let's say something like king
g1 then queen a7
knight b5 then you can just take on c1
with the check so basically you cannot
take on a7
b6 is very interesting but actually
queen e5 just wins a piece immediately
right
so there's no way of protecting this
beast you have no escape
squares for this guy here so you're
gonna
end up taking this guy on a7 so that's
why i shouldn't take
that pawn on a7 so we have not saw
many alternatives in this position
bishop d2 the problem is
that now black takes on b2 this is
actually what happened in the game and
then it gets
extremely messy we'll check dust in in a
minute
but there is a subtlety here in this
position and this is the move
a3 first because now if black goes to a5
then black screen is not targeting b2 so
basically you can't retreat now your
bishop to d2 and then black is not able
to capture on b2
and if black goes to b3 now you're able
to take on a7 and then there's no queen
a5
right okay it's true that you can play
b6
but i think for example now queen d1 is
more than enough for an advantage here
for white because if you take on b2 i
think rook a2 just
uh traps your queen right so
yeah so this is why a3 was
a little bit better than the mod that
michelle but binic uh
went for he went for a bishop g2 and now
mihail
takes on b2 and now this is crazy what
do you play with the white pieces here
it's a very important moment
actually mihail but benny played really
well you have to take in account that
black is threatening a lot of stuff i
mean
if you remove the knight from here the
rook on c1 is hanging
then bishop cc is a threat sorry the
bishop on d2 is just
pinned as well because the queen on e1
could be unprotected
some lines so what do we play here with
the white pieces
engine shows plus one something but i
can't see any move for white
yeah that's why you know sometimes it's
just not trusting the engine
uh sometimes you just have to find
positions where you feel
comfortable to play with you know
and uh and of course it's not the same
some plus one
where you actually are a clean pawn up
that
some position where you are plus one but
it's extremely crazy
hope i can watch this again please
upload this you to youtube of course we
are in youtube man this is gonna
be recorded and you you can be you can
watch this like
whenever you want in the future okay
there is no move for white for human
connoisseur is saying well bishop f1
bishop f1 yeah that's an idea but now we
should take c3
and after bishop takes c3 just queen e2
bishop takes and rook c3
and then white black's swimming so no
bishop f1
not working come on guys play like bob
bienick
did rook b2 is not legal but
i guess you mean rook b1 rook b1 is
very very strong in this position
rook b1 is very strong in this position
because now if blacks black takes on b1
then there is rook b1 and now
black has has two options let's say the
first one
is queen e3 the second is queen c2 but
one thing that you have to take in
account in this position that
the bishop on f5 and f5 sorry was
guardian e6
which is a very important square in this
position for example let's say
queen a3 now queen e6 kin h8 and
knight b5 and suddenly you're attacking
that queen suddenly you're taking
on d6 let's say you play queen e2 and
now what's the move here guys
what's the move for white
come on let's mate mihael tal yeah we
have
the option to checkmate one of the best
chess players in history
yes knight d6 that's right sacrificing
the rook
that's right because if black takes on
b1 boom
king j8 boom and
queen g8 rook takes c8 and knight f7
checkmate and then you just stand up you
know like feeling like a sir
with your monocle you know and your suit
you know and then you just
look to the audience and say you know
i'm i'm the dumb
god you know of chess but okay
uh so that's why after
this rook b1 mikhail played another move
but still we have to analyze what
happens
after uh bishop b1 rook b1 and queen c2
the problem now is that white can play
bishop b4
and the queen is actually trapped so for
example
if black takes on e4 then just queen
takes e4
and after queen d2 then there is queen
e6 followed by
queen c quincy had with the check right
so
after bishop e4 now you can try
f3 but then after queen e1 black has the
same problem
so mikhail played a fantastic move after
rook a to b1 let's see if you guys are
able to
to find this move and try to understand
why
it's so strong
chess is about patterns yeah chess is so
complicated you know i've been playing
chess since i
was like five years old you know and the
more i play you know the more i realize
i know nothing
you know f3
that's right facundo solving the issue
f3 and let's try to understand why
because yeah okay this is very beautiful
intermediate mode but why
why now okay the thing is
okay in this position mihail would be in
it two can be two
but bishop f3 now we can take on b1
rook takes b1 and queen c2
now the thing is after
bishop e4
you can actually take on e4 and now
after queen takes e4 what's the
difference now
with the previous line
now you're able to see the difference
because before there was a pawn on f4
now there's
no pawn on f4 yeah exactly this is a
game corresponding to the world
championship from 1960
that's right harsha so now you see the
difference
that's why it's so subtle you know it's
like so smooth
you know because this bishop e5 check
you cover this
important square bishop e6 and then you
can capture this guy
after king g2 let's let's say your king
one just queen takes e2 and
black is much better you are upon up and
then white has like
four islands and i mean this skin is
uh very very naked right
so this is why f3 is such a you know is
such a strong move
i mean the engines are saying that white
is fine after this move knight takes e4
and then queen takes me one and knight
takes e6 but okay
uh this was a very difficult light to
spot for mikhail binnick and he actually
didn't
but you know the thing is this white
queen is still coming to e6 but okay
after f3
now but benick took on b2 and now
mihail tal takes on e2
and we realize that now
black still appears down but then there
is a nasty pin on the c
file right there there's too much
pressure in this
knight on c3 so how do we protect this
knife yes
only move is rook b3 right
so what do we play now with the black
pieces
okay it looks very beautiful we have a
pawn on the seventh rank we have
too much pressure on c3 but then how do
we continue
right now with the black pieces just
give me some
moves guys a5 a5 well a5 is
interesting because you wanna actually
play a4 but now
this game oh
oh my tongue man what did i do
i ate myself you know [ __ ] like a
carnival you know
sorry guys
so rook b3 the problem is that white is
actually threatening to take on e2 so a5
knight takes c2 rook c1 and now yes
bishop c1 and white is enjoying
a a whole piece right
so the a5 actually is not it's not a
move here
rook takes c3 well truck takes e3 we can
just take with the bishop
or not no because now bishop takes c3
and then
actually there is no bishop guardian he
won but the thing is
black white can take with the rook and
after let's say
rook c3 rook c3 bishop takes c3 bishop
takes c3
and the bishop is guarding e1
so rook c3 is not working
rook c3 you have
more moves to give me or not
more options special e5 check well after
this move the problem is you know
after king one or king h1 you're in the
same situation you you have to find
something right but
it's a it's a valid move actually you
want queen to force a piece to move and
then capture well
e1 actually you don't achieve anything
because now this bishop is still
like doing the same thing he was doing
he's guarding c3 actually and then if
you go bishop h6 you're still not
i mean you stop putting pressure on c3
so there's no point behind e1 exactly
andre rook d4 this is a great move
rook d4 attacking the bishop on d2 and
actually
mikhail minnick had to go for bishop b1
if white plays bishop
e3 now there is a killer shot here for
for black now let's see if you guys are
able to see this move
what's up me what's up eeker son spanish
people right here too great to see you
rook takes e3 that's right now this
bishop is not covering e1 anymore so
i mean after rook c3 you just play rook
d1
and then in the next move e1 just win in
the game in the spot so
yeah bishop b3 was not possible in this
case so that's why mikhail but bienick
played
bishop e1 and now it's our turn
so how do we continue
you want to take on c3 i guess it's not
possible now yeah rook c3 because of
rook
c2 c3 or rook d1
and rookie 3 rookie one and bishop
f3 and i believe white is capturing this
pawn on e2
so it was a nice try but it's not
working in this case
rook c3 so we're gonna find something
else
rook d1 straight away okay nice try but
then i i can't take with the rook
pawn takes and knight takes d1 i think
white is holding this position maybe you
can uh
regain one piece with rook c1 but i
think it's not enough right
well maybe not even like that because i
can play bishop f3 and then protect
the knight on on on d1 so i think this
is not working either so
no rook d1 yeah bishop e1 that's a great
move
forcing this skin to go back to g1 and
now
the move that mikhail tal played was
bishop f4 you know putting a lot of
pressure on this rook and actually this
rook has no squares
if the rook goes to a1 now
your solution is working because now you
can take on c3
and then after rook c3 rook d1 and
we are covering this square with the
bishop so rook c1 is actually not
possible the rook on a1 is unprotected
and this is just winning for black
so that's why in this position mikhail
bodminik tried knight take c2
and now what do we play here this is
pretty
easy right so rook takes c1
knight takes d4 and rook e1
forcing the bishop to go to f1
and now this is just a very good
position for black after
all these mess after all these
sacrifices after all these
subtleties this s3 move finally uh
black has a normal position where he's
upon up
and he's got the bishop also the white
king has some background problems
so this is actually a a winning position
for black in practice and
mikhail didn't get some point and he
went for bishop e4
so of course we don't want to allow y to
take on f5 right
so guys don't do here bishop f5 or
something like this he takes on f5 and
then takes on b7 ending
we did something ridiculous right so
that's why you got to keep the keep the
bishop pair so bishop e4
knight e2 and then bishop e5
just protecting our pieces and bishop f6
and after rook b7 just bishop d5 this is
just still a pawn up for
for for black and why cannot
white take on a7 4c moves
4c moves captures checks and threats i'm
gonna
be insisting like this like for two
months
you know i know i'm such a
yeah bishop d4 check not immediately
that's right rook takes e2 capture
followed by a check this these are just
for c mode so there's no
difficulty in this right so bishop b2
and then
okay we have to be careful if this
bishop is not on d5 rook a8 intermediate
move will be winning so
bishop b2 and now bishop d4 check we
captured the rook and then we're
we're done with this game so that's why
white didn't take on a7 rook c7 and now
bishop a2 so this is just too much
material up
and after bishop c4 again background
problems
rka check check and rook a3
are now d5 and at the end you know
mikhail managed to
to finish this game okay this is not
very important because this is
completely winning so
let's just go till the end of the game
and let's go to the next game which is
mikhail tal against ben larson
and of course mihail tal was
e4 player so e4c5 sicilian defense
hey regards uh see somebody
from from poland i studied actually in
poland i have great memories
i i was studying one semester in
polytechnic university from gdansk
which is a city in the north of spain i
used to live in sopot
which is which is actually a holiday
place
for everybody down there and i had so
much fun you know
2011 i think 2012 eight years ago
already man i'm becoming too old
33 years old you know this is too bad
and this year actually doesn't count
yeah because we
we we are not able to do any any single
thing right with this pandemic so next
year
i'm not counting 34 you know i'll be 33
next year i don't know about you guys
but
it's gonna be like that for me how old
were you when you became a giant it was
2015 just five years ago
93 i was 27 i guess 28.
knight c6 d4 this is the open sicilian
you guys know how this variation is
called this is the rosso limo right and
uh
this is something that for example
fabiano caruana uh
played against magnus carlsen in the
world championship just a
few years ago right yeah let's keep
2020. yeah this didn't come man
they just saw one year you know i had so
many trips planned
like to latch in america and to the
states actually should be there right
now in st
louis that's why i'm doing this right
now guys because i should be the
i mean i am the grandmaster in residence
right now so normally i go there to st
louise i meet some nice people
you know this pandemic just you know
ruined everything
all right so d4 open sicilian from
mikhail tile
c takes e4 knight takes d4 e6
okay knight c3 there are many sicilians
here you can play knight f6
knight c3 e5 this is this vesnikov the
magnus is actually a great expert in
this line also d6
is the classical sicilian and you can
also play this line with e6 or even g6
going for the accelerated dragon right
so e6 knight c3 and g6 from bear larson
aiming to to to to reach this uh kind of
maybe classical sicilians transposing
with knight f6
and uh also it's possible to play queen
c7 here which leads to
the taiman of uh sicilian right
one of the most trendy sicilians
nowadays too but okay
g6 from bell larsen i'm 22. is it too
late to aim for the
uh for a title like i am in chess of
course it's it's tougher you know
i mean the later you start it's the more
difficult
that gets it's like learning a language
you know or like any other sports like
if you start playing football with 25
years so probably you won't read
you want to you want to be able to play
in real madrid but
but you can have a nice level i mean but
you can try of course
it's just a matter of hours you know and
and hard work talent is important you
know but hard work is more important
than talent
all right so g6 and
uh once we have finished its uh opening
uh
theoretical review we just go to the
game g6 bishop e3 and not f6 and here
again the different setups um
you can play uh like uh with f3 queen d2
and long castle
like some sort of english attack right
also
more calm with bishop v2 and shark
castle
and in this uh position mikhail tal went
for f for extremely aggressive move
just uh gaining some space in the center
right he wants to put the queen on f3
and then go for long castle the queen of
on f3 in this positions is
actually well placed because it supports
g4 and normally in these kind of
positions in this kind of sicilians
this uh white king is going to be
castled alongside and then the black
skin is going to be
on on on the key inside so that's why
it's actually like a race you know it's
like a whole race
where black is trying to create troubles
on the queen side
on the c file which is semi-open with
the rook
and uh white is gonna try to push pawns
like hell on the key inside right
hi sir just wanted to ask you something
as i have the opportunity what do you
think a 2000 player needs to increase
his strength further more playing more
end game lessons
well i would say a bit of everything but
in my opinion the most
important thing is tactics just do a lot
of tactics
don't uh you know don't don't study too
much
to too many openings you know it's i
mean it's it doesn't make any sense to
go
to the move fortify in the night or
without
without really understand what's what's
going on in
in in in the middle game right so
because most of the
uh games are decided by tactical shots
actually in in
in those levels yeah all right so
bishop e7 from bear larson and now queen
f3 from mikhail tal
shore castle long castle and now
queen c7 well the queen is normally well
placed on c7
and in many occasions black plays some
a6 moves just to
play prophylactically against on knight
b5
and the queen is also targeting the c2
pawn and also the the c3 knight so
normally
in all these sicilians the queen goes to
to c7 and also you know
put an eye on the e5 square so knight d
to b5 from mikhail tal putting pressure
on g6 and
the queen the queen has to go to b8
and now g4 from mikhail
a6 knight d4 and i want to ask you
something
right now after knight takes d4 has
happened in the game
bishop takes d4 now what will you play
here with the black pieces
give me your candidate moves
i don't like black position out of the
opening you know this sicilians
are very very double-edged so basically
anything can happen you know e5 looks
natural actually five is
very natural is the the first move that
came to my mind when i was analyzing
this game
b5 is also very natural so this is
actually the move that bends on lars on
the plate b5
you're gonna create counter play on the
queen side otherwise
white is gonna push the pawns g5 h4 h5
and
stuff like that but e5 is actually
very very natural so now this is the
question that i
wanted to ask you what do you play here
with the white pieces well for example
you know you're gonna know something if
the queen is on c7 after moves like e5
sometimes black white can take
and then after pawn takes there is some
queen g3 using the fact that the queen
on c7 is actually not protected but the
queen is on b8 is well protected so
this idea doesn't work in this position
so after e5 you're gonna find a solution
now
give me your solution
blah blah blah blah blah
so g5
g5 raphael found the best move in the
position that's right
g5 is very strong because now i mean
whenever this knight retreats let's say
like 98 then there are moves like knight
d5 targeting the bishop on e7 also
bishop d6 blocking everything on the
queen side
and if black takes on d4 then g takes
f6 intermediate move and now let's say
bishop f6
and knight d5 basically this queen is
out of the game
and we are actually threatening to take
this guy here ruining black spawn
structure and also creating a lot of
problems for black skin
and if black goes bishop d8 then we can
actually
i mean start an attack on the key inside
i like the move f5 here to restrict this
bishop on c8
and then basically whenever you want
you're going to be able to take this
point on d4 so you need to rush about
this
but then you're going to increase the
pressure on the g file you know you play
like alone in this position also you got
some f6 ideas
very interesting you know try to create
weaknesses on the dark squares if black
goes g6 then
h6 and g7 is a focal point where we want
to uh
drag all our pieces right and if black
doesn't
do anything or if black takes on f6 i
mean this looks completely ruined for
black right because the g file is gonna
be decisive in this
in this moment okay guys so facundo as
usual solving the issue here
and that's why in the game
ben larson where for b4 and now
what's the most natural move here i mean
we just played g4 what are we gonna play
here
queen g3 or queen g2 no right king b1
no right so what do we play here
g5 that's right just winning a tempo
just kicking this knack here
and now knight d7
and now how do we develop the pieces of
course there are
several options here for white and all
of them are very interesting but
we have to keep in mind that we want to
attack black scene
so how do we continue in this position
i mean tal was a crazy fantastic player
and then he he created here a fantastic
masterpiece sacrificing something in two
moves but
i mean a normal human being will play h4
and h5 and then try to break
with moves like g6 open files like that
right
so yeah h4 and h5 looks very natural
also another move that
another idea that you should take in
account is to sacrifice a pawn on g6 i
mean not in this position but in many
sicilian positions
mainly when there is an ideal d4 putting
pressure on e6 it's very interesting to
go
g6 because basically you are forcing
black to take with the h pawn and then
this actually
makes faster the opening of the h5
but just to to have an idea about this
but tal went for bishop d3
just all these two little monsters start
looking to this game with beautiful eyes
you know
so after b4 what do you think
that mikhail tile played in this
position
you think mihayot went for knight b1
just trying to be
safe or maybe 92 trying to be safe
you think mikhail was kirk
knight for you he you you think he went
knight a4 no
knight d5 that's right he sacrificed a
piece again
the engines don't trust in this move
but you know from the human point of
view it's very tough
to play with the black pieces as we're
gonna see
from this moment okay so black has to
take the challenge
right so it takes d5 it takes e5 and now
i want to ask you
what's the threat behind this eta xd5
for example
let's see what happens if i play knight
c5 in this position
which looks very natural actually even
the engine doesn't realize about the
danger
of this position
oh now he realized the bar just had a
heart attack right
hey kids don't try this at home that's
right
uh so
that's that's right so the thing is if
we go
queen h5 then black takes the knight on
d3
so basically black is threatening to
take the
bishop on d3 and then all our attack is
gone
so yes that's right
the best move is bishop h7 fantastic
move from
mihi king takes h7 and now
give me the next two moves next two
moves right now
well yeah next two moves then i'll ask
you more questions
take the horse says somebody
yeah queen h5 king g8 and now
bishop g7 sacrificing uh
another piece this is what uh
vladimir bukovic uh he's the author of
uh the art of attack which is uh one of
the bibles
in the in attacking chess books
right he he calls this kind of sacrifice
destructive
sacrifice i'm actually right now
recording a video series
about this book in spanish
and you know it's very interesting and
there are many examples where you
actually sacrifice to both the both the
both bishops in
in on the key inside so now give me your
next two moves because it's not that
easy right now okay we have sacrificed
even our glasses right
so even my glasses you know mikhail
tyler used to
you know just throw his glasses even
just take everything i have you know
by the way so ugly glasses that i have
right they are not even clean right now
yeah queen h6 followed by h6
that's right great now g6 and basically
we are forcing black to take on g6
otherwise they screen h7 and if black
tries to run
let's say with rook d8 then he's not
running too much after queen h7 king
effect
queen f7 and he's gotta resign
okay guys so that's why black is first
to take and then here
this is going to end pretty bad for
black like key h8
queen h6 king g8 and grook g1 this check
made in the next move keen f7 just
queen g6 and this is just game over
so that's why after it takes the fight
ben larson
saw this and then he went for f5
well the engines from today they are
suggesting g6 in this position
i know it's not easy to play this move
g6 because
you know h4 followed by h5 looks
extremely
dangerous in this position
but this was actually the best move for
black here in this position
instead he went for f5
and now what do we play here you want to
take on passant on f6
you want to push h4 h5 you want to use
the
e file for your rook
and
so what do we play here
rook h to e1 rook d2 e1
yeah i mean i like uh tal's idea he
plays rook e1 but this one because on
the default
well it's not doing much and actually
this route could help in the future on
the h file
but basically every move is just
playable at this position rookie one
rook h2 e1 h4 h5
i mean sometimes you just have to
sacrifice and then
don't expect to to check mate in like
immediately
yeah so this is so difficult to develop
this
instinct so sometimes because you know
at least for me you know
i'm a player who doesn't sacrifice that
easily you know because it's
you have to develop this kind of killer
instinct that
like players like mikhail had you know
because here i mean it's not immediate
checkmate or anything just play
you know and you have compensation of
course and and then the
the position is very complicated and
then you have to assume risks
of course so rook f7 this is the move
that ben larson played bishop d8 was the
other option here of course
but rook f7 as aaron suggest sorry
yeah that's the move that vendors have
played
so how do we proceed right now guys
how do we proceed
g6 well g6 it's interesting like uh
you have in mind uh the idea of opening
the g file but then after h
takes rook g1 something like that i
guess now black can play bishop f6
and uh he's managed to trade this bishop
d4 which is which was one of our best
attacking piece in this position so
i don't like g6 actually yeah h4 now
that's
right h4 and now you have many ideas in
this position
one of them is to play g6 now on h5
trying to open the h file
very quickly and the other one is just
to play
h5 followed by g6 and the bishop on e7
is under attack
so in this position bear larson tried to
finally develop this guy
and then he went on to play bishop b7
targeting d5
and now as you say g6 was very
interesting in this position
sorry god about the pronunciation of
very you know in spain we it doesn't
differentiate between
b and v so i mean
that's the same sound for us you know so
sorry about that guys but okay so what
do we play we have many
interesting moves here in this position
h5 g6
and the move that mihael tal played
was bishop f5 using the fact that this
bishop was under attack i mean before
before h4 bishop f5 was actually not
possible i mean was not a very good move
why let's see if you guys
find the best move for black here
actually black is winning
and i forgot to to tell you why so
that's why we're checking this right now
so
so i mean if black takes on f5 this is a
similar kind of position as
we were analyzing just before but black
doesn't need to take in this position
and the difference
is that the bishop is on c8 and not on
b7
so that's why bishop f5 is not working
here in this position because the bishop
is on c8
well knight e5 knight e5 is actually
losing because of bishop h7 king h7
and queen h5
king g8 and then we can just take this
guy here on e5 and then
the pressure is just too much right so
no
that's right knight f8 that's the point
because now
i mean you protect h7 and now if the
bishop goes back
there's bishop g5 using this pin on the
f5
so basically black is is in great shape
in this position and of course if you
take on c8 queen to xc8
and suddenly this queen is coming here
to block everything
to block everything so basically your
attack is gone
this knight is also coming to g6 too
much pressure on f4 this rook is coming
to c8
basically this is just uh fantastic for
black so
this is why you got to wait one tempo
that's why he played h4
bishop b7 and now bishop f5 because now
bishop
knight f8 actually doesn't make any
sense right
i mean you can play i don't know many
moves here even bishop h7 should work
here
because after knight h7 g6 looks also
winning but i mean you play something
like queen e4
white is also in great shape right
so that's why
ben larson went and played you know i i
become so happy you know when i check
mihail tiles games you know and i think
this happens to
every chess fan right because his games
are so you know
so fantastic today's play is like much
more accurate
but it's not so much fun in the sense
like they're so perfect you know they
don't blunder anything they don't
sacrifice
if the engine is not having your back
right so but these players you know they
used to to sacrifice everything and then
create mess
and uh it was so much fun
alright so rook takes a fight from ben
larson
bishop e6 is actually a threat in this
position
and rook f5 rook e7
and now rook g7 is actually a three
so just try to find the only move that
survives
for black in this position
how to improve chess visualization well
there's different exercises you can try
okay guys what do we play here with the
black pieces rook g7 is coming
rook f7 yeah rook f7 has a problem
after rook takes f7 keen f7
yeah i mean this is uh maybe one of the
most natural tries
and then rookie one i guess and then
queen g4
is coming um but there's another move
too here that ben larson tried
exactly this is knight e5 queen f8
is not helping you because after rook g7
you are forced to take on g7
and in these positions even though you
have two pieces
and one rook white has like three pawns
for
yeah three pawns and work and one queen
so and this game is extremely unsafe
right so you're gonna play rookie one in
this position bring the rook to the
open file if you go back then f5 is
coming
so yeah
so this is why ben larson tried knight
e5
and now let's finish the game guys as
mikhail tal did
you want to take on e5 you want to move
the queen
some well-known people from our chesony
4 channel here too
what's up guys
so yeah you want to take an e5
you want to play rook g7 maybe that's
too much right
rook g7 mr blue maybe that's too much
king takes e7 and i don't know what
what's your next move actually because
you can't take an e5
so queen e4 that's the best move i mean
if you take on e5
d take c5 i mean looks
not so clear now to me because now
i don't know uh i can't take an e5
with a pawn but still this should be
playable of course for white i mean the
position is so good that basically
everything's playable
all right spot instead queen e4 with a
double attack to the rook and the knight
on e5 so basically this position is more
or less over but
ben larson found a nice resource queen
f8
trying to attack the rook but now it's
actually rather simple to just
play f takes e5 and then the rook on f5
is just hanging so he tried
rook f4 and now queen e3
and is rook d4 working i guess no
because of rook takes b7
and the position is still quite good for
white so that's why
black kept trying to chase this queen
rook f3
and uh why not bishop takes e5 before
pinning queen and rook i don't know what
you mean
just takes d5 at this position okay but
she takes d5 rook takes c7
yeah and then if the king goes to f8
then queen h5 and then this looks
terrible for black
actually queen h7 is coming and queen h8
with the checkmate so that's why this is
not possible
but okay knight e5 queen e4 queen f5
takes
rook f3 queen e2 and now f2 square is
actually covered
so this is why finally ben larson tried
queen e7
and again mikhail after some sacrifices
he manages to get a better position with
some material up
in this case he's got like two pawns up
and a very strong bishop on d4 and a
safer king on c1
yeah so d takes e5
and now what do we play here
come on last move that's good move and
then we are ready to finish this class
and start with the next one
do that versus magnus cousin the game
that finished
the unbeaten trick from magnus carlsen
125
games in a row rookie one that's right
just spinning
this pawn on e5 and then there's no way
to protect that sword rook d8
rook takes e5 queen d6
and queen f4 nice tactics
here what happens if black takes on d5
come on forcing moves 4c moves all the
time captures checks and threats
this way you solve a lot of puzzles you
will say this stupid spanish guy all the
time telling me
you should check forcing moves i don't
want to check first it moves you know i
just want to have a mojito on the rocks
yeah rookie that's right so black is
forced to take an e8 and then the queen
is hanging
so that's why after queen f4 he went for
rook f8
queen e4 and b3 trying to open the
position up i mean after rook f1
basically kindly two and there are no
more checks
so b3 takes
rook f1 king d2 queen b4
and c3 so the point is if you take on b3
then rookie 8 followed by queen e6 just
wins
queen d6 was played bishop c5 another
sacrifice for mihitab but this time
an easier one queen takes e5 and now
finish the game
in three moves guys again forcing moves
all the time
force he moves
mojito 28 that's right
mojito 28 yeah mojito 28
like sex on the beach to f8 then
daikidi to e6 then
roman coke to h8 and finally
what to f7
yeah that's right bloody mary to f7 and
basically
has to resign ben larson has to resign
and he did in this position
because of background problems queen d5
doesn't work because of queen takes d5
and then
followed by rook fade okay so
it's always uh for me very very good and
very
you know fantastic to check
mihael tas game i mean i never get tired
of checking his games
so it was a pleasure for me to be here
with all of you i hope you guys enjoyed
this lecture
and then we are gonna shut down because
in two or three minutes
we start another lecture right here in
the saint louis
youtube channel checking games of the
week and
in particular we're gonna check duda
versus
magnus carlsen so it's been a pleasure
as usual guys take care
and if you drink don't drive bye bye